we came here and he actually got lost i
had to pick him up in the desert what
what so they say what happens in vegas
stays in vegas so before people leave
sin city we want to find out what they
got going on let's talk money all we
talk is money all we talk is money
bachelorette party she's getting married
mean hello we're about to go ziplining
the concert just having some fun we want
to do atvs we've been tour walking for
my boyfriend's tournament just for the
hell of it so are you gonna be here
partying watching shows gambling doing
it all what are you doing uh ten
thousand dollars we don't know where to
spend it so we came to vegas excuse me
you're literally here to spend money yes
as much as we can yeah i already got to
grab some ass i'm gonna suck some
we kind of crashed her cousin's birthday
man i had like four blunts like 10 shots
nicotine oh no drink yeah i locked lose
money i'll be gonna enjoy life man
that's it i don't gamble i work hard for
my money yeah i put it in investing do
you have a budget while you're here what
the [ __ ] would you come here and have a
budget
i made sure i worked hard all week yeah
i'm thrifty i'm like warren buffett i'm
a bottle on a budget but we still gonna
bother the [ __ ] out there is no such
thing as a budget
because it's a bachelorette party we try
but my husband does like to gamble and i
do like the slots i always say i have a
budget but i'm trying to do what i want
to do while i'm here sort of budgets
really i'm just good at keep it and what
what does your bag say salary inside but
there's don't be fooled there's nothing
in there don't be fooled best guess how
much you think you'll end up spending in
vegas like a kidney
yeah 35 000. six thousand four grand
probably around a thousand it depends
how many days you're staying until my
credit card gets declined
you've seen the movie the hangover right
yeah okay so we're asking people like
your biggest hangover story moment that
you've had well actually my fiance from
my 30th we came here and he actually got
lost i had to pick him up in the desert
what what we almost got kidnapped the
day after we were hung over it was
really bad i just had a baby a year ago
and i'm like holy [ __ ] so i put my
shades on him
carlos we were like driving to my dinner
and we were already a couple shots in
and went down this median like dead eyes
my friend broke her toe i won a twerking
contest so it entailed 500 worth of
bottle service and we went out to three
different nightclubs in cabo the next
morning i woke up the most hungover in
my whole life and i had to go on a
excursion i almost probably died i was
going to halloween week in college and i
don't remember that whole week i threw
up all over my ex's car and then the
next morning it was just he broke up
with me i lost my car i lost my wallet
and i woke up with my sneakers all dirty
i'm about to have it tonight
you know how they say what happens in
vegas stays in vegas he's in vegas what
do you want to happen that you don't
want anybody to know oh [ __ ] i'ma go on
a pole and just go crazy that's all i
gotta say i need to wake up with four
strippers next to me yeah i don't wanna
learn that yeah i don't need you you
don't want her to be dumb
i hope that one of my single friends
gets lucky
you want one of your friends to get laid
yeah i ain't no snitch [ __ ] so i
ain't telling y'all [ __ ]
i ain't no stick that's my guy
there's really nothing to admit i'm a
good girl
how much money i'm gonna possibly lose i
don't know you've been here long enough
this is a party crew it's a great little
party crew right here we got party girl
blunt smoker we got throw up girl losing
a boyfriend didn't remember her entire
halloween week and she's never the sweet
one has never done anything wrong in her
life first kiss last night
hold on hold on what is that what do you
mean first time you've ever kissed
somebody yeah who was this special
person some guy i don't know him like
that i mean it was nice but i don't
remember half of it give some people a
hot tip at home about being frugal but
still getting the lovely ladies hey i'm
gonna tell you this only spend your
money if you want to you work hard spend
your [ __ ] money you deserve it
always treat yourself that's it man give
us just like your biggest vegas recap
what you want people to understand about
you and everything you're doing go ahead
young ballerina stripper right here
you know what just let loose live life
to the fullest and just go crazy have
fun save your money and oh yolo you only
live once have fun get messed up try to
avoid the crackheads though they're
crazy that's uh that's great advice
during not think about consequences
that's it that's it you're a total
sweetheart okay so you're awesome
respect to you sweetie final thoughts
wrap it up on
making money spending money saving
investing you know biggest takeaway for
the people at home best advice just be
wise with your money look it doesn't
grow on trees you know make sure you top
out your 401ks or your roth iras do the
right thing and uh more importantly
always save a budget aside to have fun
that's awesome and that's vegas baby now
you know why they call it sin city and
as much as they say what happens in
vegas stays in vegas we sure found out
what people are up to out here and what
they're not up to is saving that money
so before you roll out to vegas make
sure you roll up with a budget and save
that money all we talk
is money